we are very excited about our next two
guests yes we are yeah we sure are actor
daniel kaluya
who starred in hit movies like get out
and black panther
he just won his first golden globe award
for the film judas and the black messiah
in the movie he plays fred hampton who
was chairman of the illinois
chapter of the black panther party
here's a look at the real fred hampton
and kaluya's portrayal of him
but you can't tell them you can run a
revolutionary but you can't run a
revolution
and you can murder a freedom fighter but
you can't marry the freedom
the film highlights how an fbi informant
william o'neill
infiltrated the black panther party to
gather information on hampton before he
was killed in 1969.
hampton died during a police raid at his
home when he was just 21 years old
shaka king directed produced and
co-wrote the movie
he joins us now with daniel kalia good
morning to you both thank you both for
being here we really really appreciate
it
good morning daniel first of all
congratulations on the golden globe that
had to be even though you couldn't
we couldn't hear you at first that had
to be a great moment
no it was a great moment it was a great
moment and i'm so happy
they took me off me yeah yeah um
you say daniel you say that that this
this wasn't
just a physical assassination uh that
fred hampton suffered but there was also
a cultural
assassination that went with it what do
you hope to change
or help people know with this film well
um just hope to tell the truth
it's like the truth of the matter is
that what they were doing they were
in the communities um with the medical
clinic
helping kids educating kids feeding kids
and with the rainbow coalition they did
incredible work and chairman fred
is um the thought leader of a lot of
incredible strategies that i hear in
society today
shaka i'm a child of the 60s so i'm
pretty amazed that we've reached a point
and i know even though it's 60 years
later
that we now have a movie about fred
hampton and there's also a second movie
trial of chicago
7 features fred hampton as a supporting
character uh
how hard was it to get for you to get
this film made
um well you know every every film has
its challenges
uh you know it took us about four years
and you know it was difficult to find a
studio to partner with us but ultimately
we found warner brothers and
you know i couldn't have really
envisioned a better partner quite
frankly
daniel i heard you say that you gave
everything in this role and when i saw
it i tell you i watched it yesterday
guys i signed up for hbo max
just so i could watch the movie but i
heard you say that you gave
everything in this role and that you
felt free how did you
decompress after because it's so intense
and it's so emotional
and you were knocked out in it your
knockout thank you so much i think i'm
still decompressing it i think um
doing this press run you still you're
reminded about little things that you
were doing and during the process so
i think it took a while like last year
like the pandemic was
was actually a good thing for me this
first time i sat down for like five six
years
so i had to kind of reassess where my my
insights were
you know shaka the thing that impressed
me or struck me i should say
is that i'd heard of fred hampton i knew
how he died
a i didn't know he was 21. i certainly
didn't know his life story and after the
movie i started googling
it was fascinating all the things i
learned but there's a line in the movie
where the fbi agent who's trying to flip
uh the uh the fbi william o'neill which
he ultimately did
he said listen the black panther party
and the ku klux klan clan are basically
the same thing
and i sat there watching that and went
huh is this part of the story you're
trying to tell that people really know
what the black panther party represented
because people think of it as a militant
organization
and certainly there's aspects to that
but there's so much more to the black
panther party
yeah absolutely i mean i think you know
one of the reasons that we wrote that
line
um was just you you hear those
comparisons
even made today you know when when they
compare for example the capital
capital rioters to you know members of
black lives matter
you know and and you look at you know
the way that those individuals at the
capitol who
you know how they are not going to
nearly face the kind of prosecution that
you know
uh a protester who set a trash can on
fire
you know in ferguson it's me while
getting eight years so
um that that's really the reason we put
that that line in there to just
you know kind of destroy those parallels
to today in a lot of ways yeah
it's important daniel i'm curious about
your preparation
yeah for the role because number one the
speaking style is very distinct
you have some very emotional passionate
speeches
how did you prepare for that with my
amazing dialect coach audrey lecrone
um he just diligently did a lot of work
and then working with shakashaka helped
me and guided me a lot
then i sat down with the opera singing
coach because i felt chairman fred
sonically occupied the space like an
opera singer
so he was really grateful to engage my
diaphragm and condition my vocal chords
for those 12-hour days which is really
tough
and also study cadence because he had a
different cadence to when he spoke
so um it was a lot of work that went
into it shaka you worked with fred
hampton's family
throughout writing and the filming
stages of this are are they happy with
the outcome
they are you know it it it took a while
for us to kind of find those points of
interest
um but but ultimately you know
they the fact they still talk to me
that's usually a good sign that that's
that's a positive side
you didn't know we didn't know every day
what he was going to end up no
that's the best endorsement you could
get daniel i do want to go back to the
golden globes because you're the first
one out the box
i didn't know if you were on mute or if
they had you on mute but i'm so glad
that they worked it out what were you
thinking in that moment
when i was on mute yeah i was like
they put me on mute
but they were they were moving on they
were like congratulations i'm watching
it
i didn't put myself on you i didn't put
myself off me i thought it was their
responsibility i don't know it wasn't
clear it was just a miscommunication yes
well i'm glad that it was i was just
i felt just so blessed that like more
people were going to watch this film
yeah that is yeah i want people to to
understand chairman fred i understand
the black panther party understand what
they did in that time
that is definitely going to happen oscar
nominations are coming up i can't wait
gentlemen
i can't wait yeah and i got a note from
my son from college who said dad you got
to watch this film yeah and he was right
jaka king and daniel kaluuya thank you
so much we appreciate it